vyas next summer yes isn't it Tyreese
isn't that Theresa Jared Leto
and Tyrese actually told me I was
peeking him a couple weeks ago he
actually told me that they do in the
Morbius movie but then it's uh they all
have deals to do three other movies
really yeah so me and he did say to me
that it would all be in the MCU whoa so
we just got that exclusive right here
that's crazy he did say that so he said
that he's gonna cross over into the MCU
you think he's lying or you think he's
down the truth did you know something
that nobody else knows I don't think he
would have any reason to lie I mean I
don't know Toni Sony's prettier more
because it's a spider-man character yeah
interesting yeah but he did say that um
they're doing the Morbius movie and it
is they're gonna intern MC you what I
mean all that's gonna intertwine over
that's blade that's what I'm saying
that's why I was like they need to make
this deal happen because you could do a
blade you could do a blade versus more
based on the line even if Morbius isn't
good I would still love to see um
rehearsal Ali's Blade vs giant Leto is
Morbius how's it going everybody it's
Warren and as you just saw in a really
really interesting way we have learned
that the Sony universe and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are going to be
crossing paths and could essentially end
up becoming one universe now if you're
unfamiliar with what is being said in
this interview
don't worry I'll break it all down I
will talk about Sony's plans for their
spider-verse and we'll talk about
Marvel's plans for their MCU to
interconnect with each other
specifically in regards to spider-man
venom carnage blade and Morbius so I'll
break all that down in this video but
quick reminder if you'd like a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain and also if you are
trying to win that Nintendo switch there
is only about nine hours left in the
giveaway so be sure to go over and
follow me on Twitter and click the link
in the description down below for your
chance to win so in this video we have
Charlamagne tha God who is a radio host
for a few different stations talking
about how Tyrese Gibson who is going to
be playing an FBI agent in the upcoming
Morbius film toll
Charlamagne that he has signed on to do
three different movies and they're all
going to be in the MCU now this is huge
news because this means that the Sony
Universe and the Marvel Universe are
finally going to be one even if it's
just for a few different movies but this
does make sense given the fact that Sony
and Marvel just worked out a deal for
spider-man to remain in the MCU and
we've been hearing rumors that
spider-man is also going to be appearing
in the Sony Universe as well and it does
make sense for Morbius to take place in
the MCU Morbius first appeared in 1971
in the amazing spider-man at 101 as an
antagonist to spider-man now we've known
for some time that Sony is developing a
Morbius aka the living vampire movie the
movie is going to start Jared Leto Matt
Smith Adria our Jonah and Tyrese Gibson
and again in this video Tyrese Gibson
told Charlamagne that these films are
going to take place in the MCU
and this makes a ton of sense because
there are so many characters that can
interconnect between the two universes
not just spider-man venom and carnage
but now we could do a Morbius versus
blade Kevin Feige at San Diego comic-con
announced that we are getting a new
blade movie and since blade hunts
vampires and Morbius is a vampire it
makes perfect sense for these two Marvel
characters to eventually connect and be
in a movie together now obviously that
is not possible if Sony owns the rights
to Morbius and Disney owns the rights to
blade and their universes were two
separate universes that didn't connect
so in order to get a Morbius vs. blade
movie the two universes would have to
connect and now according to this video
they are and this is huge news this is
something that everybody has been
wanting for quite some time now no more
separation between the venom universe
and the spider-man universe and the MCU
this means that spider-man can interact
with the venom and carnage this means
that Deadpool can interact with venom
something that fans have really wanted
for spider-man 3 is for venom to appear
or Deadpool to appear and now it seems
like either in spider-man 3 or another
movie down the line it's possible for
both to happen and again we know that
Sony and Disney were just in
negotiations for spider-man before civil
war came out Marvel and Sony worked out
a deal for spider-man to be
in the MCU perhaps they worked out some
deals for other characters to jump over
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe as well
especially since they have renegotiated
a deal recently because again Tyrese
Gibson told Charlemagne that these
Marvel characters that are owned by Sony
are going to be appearing in the MCU so
we have two universes colliding which
leads to a very very exciting feature
for the MCU what do you all think about
this are you excited to see these two
universes combine and no longer have to
separate the two or do you think that
they should remain separate let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe to
my channel and like this video so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and if you're
trying to win that Nintendo switch it is
the very last day of the giveaway so be
sure to follow me on twitter and click
the link in the description down below
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof